hey Aaron so it turns out you just got
back from a secret mission at Bungie so
you got all these fun details to share
with me and the rest of our community
tell us what you saw
yeah we got to play through a lot of
Forsaken and there is so much destiny in
in this destiny this time around a lot
of people were hoping that this would be
the taking king-sized DLC for destiny to
the one that revitalized everything and
tweet weapons and added a ton of new
areas we spend a day with it and it
feels like it's definitely that size
possibly larger now just for folks out
there we played a lot of content but we
were only allowed to capture some of it
and all that I can show you while we're
having this conversation is the first
couple of story missions and exploring
the tangled chore so my apologies I
won't actually be able to show you a lot
of what we're talking about but bear
with us and we'll get through as much as
we can without breaking embargoes but
the games out today so you'll be able to
play through a lot of this yourself
after you listen to us
so Aaron you mentioned you know being
able to show some of the campaign you
know like tell us a little bit about you
know your experience with the campaign
how is the story this time around we
kind of know you know this this story is
kind of set around a revenge story in a
sense that you know we're doing this for
Kade and you know my hope is that
somehow we revive Kade but you know it
looks like the man's pretty dead and
it's kind of scary actually because I
thought about it and I was like dude
Kate's probably one of the best
characters that's in destiny too so
killing him off kind of scares me
it is really risky for them to kill off
one of their best characters in the game
particularly because storytelling has
not always been Bungie strong suits
they're they're fantastic writers like
the grimoire is great and then the Lord
tabs are great but but killing off the
one character that's really entertaining
is a risk and you know we already know
he's dead from publicly available
trailers the star of the show of the
first couple hours because you already
know what happens is really the where
takes place forsaken really builds on
the reef and the prison of elders and
you know without getting too specific it
knows what you've already done if you
play through house of wool
and it kind of plays off of your
expectations of what's gonna happen in a
way that'll make you feel very nostalgic
and also messes with kind of what you
expect to happen at certain times all I
can say is that you get you get into the
inner workings of the prison of elders
like going under the Roman Colosseum and
seeing what the gladiators were doing
you know before they got lifted up to
their deaths and also there's a lot of
story elements in the tangled Shore you
get to explore some of the cultures of
the Fallen so they've always been
they've mostly been enemies they were
allies to the Queen and you you get to
dig into them a lot more like spider is
your quest giver he's like the sheriff
in town
and he sends you through your first
exploration of the tangled Shore coming
off the main story so one important
thing to talk about is is the grind the
story starts are we at the preview event
we started at about 380 and so anybody
who's at 380 you should easily be able
to get through the first buy the story
the tangled chore went up to about 500
power level and then you know honey
hunting barons took you also up to about
like about to a point in the 500 range
where you couldn't do it you probably
have to go do something else for a while
okay so you kind of get capped in a way
so like it seems like it has pretty good
progression in terms of like okay you're
gonna start story yet you know whatever
light you're at now roughly right like
you said you started around 380 then you
know as you progress through the story
it seems like it gets you to the point
where as a tango short opens up it
pretty much gives you everything you
need to do to get to like that maybe
that 500 soft dish cap that then you're
going off to another area so to speak
yeah so we've played in the Dreaming
city although I am under embargo can't
talk about it but again like we can talk
about these things later today mm-hmm
when people get there like our embargo
as we can talk about the Dreaming city
when we get to the Dreaming city I'll
say that it's above it's definitely
above the light level of tangled Shore
and it's another high level exploration
zone
to be vague there's a lot of exploring
to do in the second zone and also that
you know like they've already talked
about the blind well and shown some
footage of it but that's another place
for you to grind and progress I can't
say that it's very similar to the court
of Oryx it's larger but I don't want to
get into specifics just yet about what
you do there okay and I guess I didn't
ask you this but how big do you would
you say the tangled Shore is like like
relative to kind of some of these
planets that we've been exploring is it
kind of like big or is it like
medium-sized like what would what planet
would you kind of mirror that off of if
you could so the tangled Shore is I
would say a medium sized map it's a
bunch of asteroids lashed together I
believe it at about five zones to it
there's a lot of stuff under it -
there's prison cells there's law sectors
there's mines we definitely saw story
gated content like there was a fallen
skiff that clearly like crossed a chasm
that I couldn't get to without the
Fallen skiff so I'm assuming this will
all be part of the story the story
actually takes place on the tangled
Shore so it does that thing where you
get story and cutscene and then you have
to go grind for a while and it gets
story and cuts me and grind for a while
yeah I would say his planets go it's
about medium size and the you know again
being vague the Dreaming city was large
it was definitely felt much bigger than
the tangled Shore okay so unfortunately
as you mentioned like we can't really
speak to that yet you know we'll
probably speak more to it once we kind
of see it ourselves but that seems to be
the late-game
sans the raid right also I guess during
their the the preview were you able to
fight some of the new enemies I think
there is it the scorn
yeah the scorn were really interesting
they're not massively different from
other races that I mean they're fallen
who have been corrupted by ether by
corrupted ether but they have a lot of
specialized movesets that tend to push
you around the map so in destiny one I
feel like a lot of the design which I
which forsaken kind of draws influence
from was there to pit you with minimal
cover against things that just had like
a power or a light level and you had
your power light
if they didn't match up you're kind of
screwed so I was worried that this was
mirroring that philosophy but there's a
lot of cover in this DLC so you can move
and fight and be creative with your new
abilities there's like nine new subclass
trees some of them are our support
abilities so when you go toe-to-toe with
the scorn a lot of what they do is mess
with your space so they either run at
you and explode but they're more
aggressive but the explosions are
smaller than the thrall okay so they're
easier to dodge but they have it more
often then there's ones that will run up
in the swing fire lanterns at you and
keep put down small area like
area-denial sections there's ones that
will spawn traps that'll actually trap
you in and burn you there's a really
standout one that floats around the map
as mist and then appears and takes
sniper shots at you and then like floats
off again and it's more or less seems to
be involved a
but it looks so cool like when you see
it happen it's impressive to look at and
then there's this like funny little dude
with a shield
it's like a small gladiator shield and
you just kneecap him all day and that
takes him down and I hope he's not like
a failing phalanx is are literally the
worst because they essentially almost
have super armor yeah and they're just
paying the butt so I hope this guy's not
a pain in the butt but it'll be fine
they also redid some enemies you fought
for a while like fallen walkers have
some new move sets they have a
flamethrower which kind of keeps you
from getting too close but then when
they go into their vulnerable state they
put up a shield so you can no longer
just snipe them with your whisper of the
worm or Blair's land up yeah you got
actually work with your team now and run
in to hit the correct spot when it goes
into vulnerable state so shotgun city
got you can have three shotguns if you
want so tying in to that is the new
exotics we got to play with the
malfeasance hand cannon which a lot of
people affectionately compared to the
needler okay and being a warlock I was
also playing with chromatic fire which
was cool because malfeasance was in my
kinetic slot and chromatic fire makes
anything in your kinetic slot make
elemental explosions on crit like
headshots yep so
malfeasance already makes everything
explode after five hits and then this
exotic chess piece also made everything
explode on critical headshots so
basically a lot of [ __ ] exploded while I
was shooting at it it was a really good
ads clearing weapon or like set up and I
think a lot of this DLC is based around
you coming up with creative loadouts
well the flip side of that is you can
come out you can come up with bat
loadouts so this because the scoring are
so aggressive carrying two shotguns is
actually a bad idea because or like a
shotgun and a hand cannon without an
armor and armor piece that makes you
reload faster because if you have a lot
of downtime in between reloads the scorn
will probably get you while while you're
reloading and you can screw up and build
a bat loadout yeah I mean that is part
of the fun and interesting thing I mean
like it's been out for a week now but
it's still taking getting used to
obviously and it's always interesting to
see how the meta changes you know so I
am excited about the potential for you
know weapons like malfeasance and you
know just seeing what the next best
legendary is but you also got to play
around with some of the new superpowers
why don't you tell me some something
about that because I think you mainly
played warlock right this time around
yes I only had time really to mess with
warlock but I will say that Titan also
has some good support abilities and
those are important in some of the
higher level content for you to be able
to go toe-to-toe with things we were we
were in a place where we were actually
fighting things 50 powers power levels
above us okay and we succeeded for a
while relying on some of these new
abilities but the warlock has a couple
of interesting ones there are more
tweaks on the existing powers than full
I don't know new I like giant new ideas
so the void Walker has the Nova warp
which is really cool it's basically lets
you be a nova bomb and it's much more
strategic rather than just one big
explosion you get to make a lot of
little explosions and you control how
big those explosions are it's it's like
being able to do divide up your Nova
bomb how you want to divide it up rather
just throw it once and either do what
you meant to do or say whoop sand then
have to wait for it to come back again
but it also has a teleporter which is
really cool because again this game has
a lot of exploration and some of the
enemies were way above our level and we
used it to just teleport past things
that were too high level for us and
interesting like explore beyond them in
the map so it's kind of a fun way to get
an advanced look at things that you
otherwise couldn't fight I know that the
hunter also can basically just go
invisible for long periods of time now
with like old-school yeah
the stormcaller is chaos reach was
probably the least impressive of the
bunch that poor like electric lightning
has just never been all that impressive
like it's good at little guys and this
just basically channels it all into one
direct energy beam that's a long range
and it took care of like regular yellows
but when you hit a big boss it didn't
feel like it did that much so that one
was okay I think I don't know I feel
like storm collars always been just very
situational it's oh yeah it's definitely
it's been a little bit better but like
like you said is it's specifically for
like ad clear and things like that it's
really strong and ad clear if you combo
with like chrono tempest it makes it
last longer so then you can just you
know for certain you know raid things or
and like public events or something like
that you can just like clear all this
stuff out it's not necessarily the most
DPS to a boss I don't think it ever has
been but you know it's nice to have
options obviously and then dawn blades
well radiance is the one where you plant
the sword in the ground and you get a
buff to yourself in your team
anybody within the well that was the one
that I originally thought was the least
interesting and it ended up being it
just turns the warlock into a tank like
just a damaged soaking tank it was
incredible there was there was one point
where we were getting burned by an
environmental mechanic shot by a boss
directly and hit by all the like ads
around and we just stood there
practically invulnerable and and took
care of business it's it's definitely up
there with both the older Titan bubble
in my mind in terms of your ability to
just soak damage but unlike the Titan
bubble this timer with with the well the
radiance you can keep firing out of it
so it would take the only thing that
really dislodged us from from it was
when bosses did a stop and yeah if you
get punted out of it or pumped it up or
something like that yeah did you uh
because I don't know that much about the
ability but did you is it like a
basically a stronger rift it's that's
exactly what it is it's just a baby both
empowering and healing riff though it's
I believe it gives you both plus you can
also use your regular rift so if you
have to in the in the case I'm talking
about we actually had two warlocks who
both dropped well of radiance and their
regular rifts at the same time so
basically anybody inside of that have
vortex of Awesomeness outputted a ton
more damage and can soak a ton of damage
and it almost lets you get around some
of the mechanics of the game so yeah I
think it's gonna be one of the the fan
favorites when it comes to doing any
sort of hard activities in the game yeah
it sounds a really cool just to have
more of a support option like a like a
true support like Super Mom and like
like you said I think it'll be
interesting to see how that works out
for you know like obviously it's gonna
be really good in the raid it's probably
like a must-have I would think unless
it's like a mobile fight and it sounds
like something I'd probably be running
for like strikes and knife balls to you
because like chances are you know a
Titan or hunter is gonna have other good
supers to like you know either ad clear
or kill the boss and you know maybe with
like whisper and you're just chilling in
your although that could break it I
don't know we'll see
alright so to wrap this up raid comes
out 10 days after launch we had a QA
session where the devs basically said
they expected an average person will be
able to unlock two new subclass trees in
that amount of time and they designed it
so that the grind takes ten days that's
what they claimed it takes 10 days so
you have more time to get ready for the
raid but they also feel like they
designed it so that you'll need that
time to get ready
for the raid my guess is they want you
to actually engage with all the other
content first or you can look at it as
them kind of finding a way to gate
people from you know getting through
their stuff too fast now granted haven't
seen the game in full yet so if there's
a lot of cool stuff to explore I don't
mind that I don't mind kind of soaking
in all that stuff that they've kind of
put in place of us to try and to to you
know explore and to actually get to that
level because then yeah you do feel a
little bit more accomplished when you
kind of spent ten days and got like you
know like I think I'm raid ready and
then realize I'm probably still not raid
ready you know outside of like the small
you know 5% of you know those people are
that that are really gonna min/max it
but I'm hoping when they say that like
most people will be ready by ten days
that they're kind of aiming more towards
like you know your average player maybe
not a casual player but somewhere in
between because you know that would be
good I think one and two you know at
least they've come forward and already
said like hey if you do challenging
things they're gonna reward you for
doing challenging things right so you
know it'll be really fun to watch at
least for me that you know the people
are trying to get world-first something
like things like that because they have
brought cool new systems you know
forward like you know you're gonna have
like those special like names and
everyone's gonna see like you're the you
know special person that did this and
that and then also I guess if you're
super like the 3 to 5% you're gonna have
like some really sick raid gear that you
know some people might not have the you
know in 10 days but and on the flip side
of that people who don't raid in destiny
have a high level zone the Dreaming city
that it's it's the equivalent for for
those folks so they'll be able to
explore that zone and fight high level
enemies without having to have a crew to
fight with and there's also just a lot
of secrets in that zone again can't go
into specifics until later today but
there's a lot to do for both people who
love to raid and for people who just
love to stop and smell the roses
explore areas it just feels like there's
a ton of secrets and we haven't even
gotten into we did not see or haven't
gotten into the other realms that are
kind of around these the Dreaming city
that they've talked about in the Vedic I
mean there's like there's literally
entire other realities kind of around
that map hi and we don't quite know how
you'll get into them yet
I think Game Informer talked about one
that you only get one shot a week to get
into and with one life so I'm really
looking forward to to this dlc and kind
of the long the long play that it's
making cuz we don't really know when the
next destiny is even gonna happen yeah I
mean they've already you know that it
won't happen for a year that's for sure
because they've already pretty much
shown us a road map of here's a year
worth of DLC so I don't expect destiny 3
anytime soon I'm really hoping that with
forsaken it is like that taking king
sized you know DLC expansion because it
is $40 of course which is you know like
the equivalent of two DLCs right so but
it you know last time I could at least
say you know with taking King this that
was a really good expansion and one that
people should come in play if you had
fallen off I'm hoping that's the same
for Forsaken and in real talk I think
we're probably gonna play this on and
off over the next year we'll probably
walk away and go play Division two and
go play anthem and I think you can do
that pretty guilt-free
this is a very large DLC from what we
saw and you'll have you know they have
their season pass but you'll have the
next year to just get through it at your
own pace and also play other other hot
titles that you want to play I feel like
this gives you a lot of room to do that
and that's that's really cool in my mind
alright awesome so that was our preview
for forsaken you guys will be basically
playing playing forsaken if you bought
it by the time you hear this so we'd
love to hear your thoughts on on this
DLC whether you feel like it's gonna
keep your attention over the next year
if you think it delivered on the taking
king sized DLC promise let's talk about
in the comments below and and thanks for
watching everyone
you